everyday everything I'm doing I'm asking
why can't it be done faster why can't I
accomplish more right now that it's not
okay to put something off even till
tonight I need to do it right now the
only way that you're going to be able to
push past the mountain of obstacles that
is going to try to stop you
is to have maniacal focus to know
exactly what you want
I built a billion-dollar business
without setting an alarm prioritize
sleep need motivation watch a top 10
with believe nation
what's that believe nation it seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's get your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack and join today's lessons
from a man who went from growing up in a
morbidly obese family to being dead
broke and not being able to pay his
bills to building a billion-dollar brand
now wanting to build the studio to rival
Disney and pull people out of the matrix
he's Tom Billiam and here's my take on
his top ten roses success vol 6 also if
you want to know what Tom and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my confidence to 54 series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a short 30 second to five
minute video absolutely for free to help
you build your confidence check out the
link in the description below there's a
gap between who people are and what they
tell you they want to accomplish because
in the beginning I hired everyone
everyone right not because I'm super
smart and thought hey I should there was
no one else right like we had the
smallest handful of people ever and so I
started doing the interviewing as I was
doing it I start realizing God these
guys tell me they want to do something
amazing with their life and if you just
listen like wow yeah like I want to be
in your team dude you're gonna do
amazing stuff and then you realize they
can't execute on that dream so if I
can't think they don't have the mindset
yet
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one put in the work
alright listen and listen well because
no truer words are ever gonna be spoken
you can do anything you want without
limitation whatever it is that you
decide you want to make come true in
your life you can do that it is gonna
take an inhuman amount of work you're
gonna have to be prepared to break
yourself in half you are going to have
to learn more than anyone has ever
learned you can have to push yourself
harder than anyone has ever asked you to
push yourself before you're gonna go way
beyond your breaking point you're gonna
run until you vomit you're gonna study
until you fall asleep you're going to
push and push and push and then you're
gonna push them anymore and when you hit
the limit you're gonna push again beyond
that you're gonna force yourself into an
adaptation response and why because it's
Malcolm X said the future belongs to
those who prepare for it today so if you
don't put the work in that's a day if
you don't do the unending back-breaking
work of developing yourself into
something greater the world is gonna
pass you by the people that are going to
own it are going to be the ones that did
the one promise that I can make you
right now is that somebody somebody out
there is out working somebody right now
is doing the things that I'm saying
somebody right now is doing the work of
failing and getting up and getting
better and pushing themselves and
triggering that glorious adaptation
response that makes humans the apex
predator someone right now they're
putting in that work and if you don't
the future is going to belong to them
and as Martin Luther King jr. said you
can't fly then run if you can't run then
walk if you can't walk then fall but
whatever you do you have to keep moving
forward it's not okay to make excuses
it's not gonna slow people down it's not
okay to ask the world to stop so that
you can step out front it's not okay to
expect a little of yourself and demand
great rewards the only thing that's okay
is to be in line with the way that the
world really works and if you want to be
great you've got to become capable and
great you've got to develop your skill
set you've got to take what you have now
and if that's crawling and you crawl but
you drag yourself ever forward to a
vision of yourself that is so clear and
so specific that
because you my friends know exactly
where you're going you're willing to pay
whatever price it takes to get there and
no matter what anybody says no matter
how many hecklers come for you no matter
how many people try to fill dirt on you
try to stop you try to knock you down no
matter how many people come for you at
night while you sleep
and you will keep pushing forward and
you will get better every day and no
matter how many times people chop at you
knock you down knock you off the path we
will get back on you will cross them you
can walk you walk too
my friends is the only path forward so
if you want the future that makes you
happy if you want to warm that you're
excited about get your ass out there and
earn it
rule number two don't be passive
recently you talked about ditching
patience but I think patience helps in
the long run why do you think ditching
patience will help this is so
fascinating so patience in the long run
is the only thing that I can tell you is
guaranteed to fail there may be some
advantage to what people are the reason
that people are telling you to have
patience in the short term because
here's what anybody trying to anybody
telling you to have patience is trying
to get you to understand one very simple
thing whatever you're trying to
accomplish it takes a very long time and
so if you go into it and you're playing
this short-term game game chances are
you're gonna do things that are damaging
to your reputation long term that to me
is not patience that to me is playing
the long game you want to play the long
game you want to be authentic you want
to be a good person you want to do good
things from people you want to invest in
other people not because you're being
patient because patient to me is a very
passive position it's saying look I'm
not gonna like go all out today because
at the end of the day this is gonna take
time this is a marathon it's not a
sprint and so I need to pace myself
that's what people hear when you tell
them to be patient I know because I've
seen it play out thousands of times so
what happens when you tell people be
patient is you're telling them hey look
this is gonna take a really long time
anyway so pace yourself here's the
reality and you're you're gonna feel the
truth of this instantly most dreams
never come true most of the people that
you know most of the dreams that you've
had for yourself they haven't come true
why not because they're brutally
difficult the world is going to resist
you it is not going to be easy to
overcome entropy to overcome inertia the
only way that you're going to overcome
that stuff is
to go all-out everyday knowing that it's
gonna take a long time but the only way
that that dream is gonna come true even
over that long period of time is if
you're going all-out every day so
literally a mantra in my life and I
can't I cannot stress this enough this
is a cornerstone of why I've been able
to achieve at the level that I've been
able to achieve every day everything I'm
doing I'm asking why can't it be done
faster why can't I accomplish more right
now that it's not okay to put something
off even till tonight I need to do it
right now now you need to get very good
at prioritizing because if you try and
do everything right now you're going to
accomplish nothing and if you're trying
to be gimmicky or do shortcuts all of
that's gonna fail because none of that
is playing the long game but if ever
you're allowing yourself to slow down
because you simply are acknowledging
that this stuff takes time I'm telling
you it's never going to work you've got
to go all-out you've got to create
momentum rule number three have maniacal
focus this is critical whatever it is
that you're going to do in your life if
you have any interest in doing something
extraordinary if you have any interest
in performing better than other people
if you have any interest in doing
something that will be remembered this
is the takeaway for you pick one thing
and do it with force and determination
the only way that you're going to be
able to push past the mountain of
obstacles that is going to try to stop
you is to have maniacal focus to know
exactly what you want to have clarity of
purpose to have a crystal clear vision
in your mind of what you're trying to
accomplish something that you could tell
anybody in a single sentence when you
have that and you stare at it all day
and you think about exactly how you're
gonna make it happen and you tie your
identity to it then you've got a chance
because then my friends when that
obstacle comes before you you will
muster the force that you need to
destroy that obstacle and this is where
this kind of aggressive language and
thinking is going to help you because
they will not go quietly and that's the
problem that a lot of good gentle
beautiful Souls have is when the time
comes they don't muster the force that's
required to get what they want and I
know you know like I do somebody who's a
beautiful person who's a good human
being that we wish good things for but
sometimes bad things happen because they
don't stand up for themselves and as
jaco willing said most of us aren't
defeated in one decisive battle we're
defeated one tiny seemingly
insignificant surrender at a time that
ships away at who we should really be
that's how we lose rule number four
optimize your life how important is rest
and how much do you get of it I'm trying
hard at the moment to pursue my dreams
but sometimes I feel out of balance
because I lack sleep for example all
right boys and girls I'm telling I'm
just gonna be super arrogant for a
second I built a billion-dollar business
without setting an alarm prioritize
sleep I work a lot in fact I'll take the
Pepsi challenge anybody that wants to go
head to toe with me in terms of what you
get done not just raw number of hours
aimed at a computer or whatever it is
you're supposed to be doing and
performing totally sub-optimally I'll
just take the Pepsi challenge on that I
always prioritize sleep I always
prioritize my psychological optimization
so for instance if I'm working around
the clock if this happened not too long
ago I was just working so many hours and
it ended up encompassing too many things
that took more energy than they were
giving that I started to feel anxious
isn't in fact I started to feel
claustrophobic that's exactly how I felt
I wanted to crawl out of my own skin I
don't know how to explain it it's just
like ah was driving me
and I realized I need to chill for a
minute I need to meditate I need to take
an hour and go do something that's still
moving me towards my dreams because
that's my thing but that I really enjoy
and so maybe in those moments I go read
a comic because we're building a comic
book publishing Empire so that's part of
what I need to do anyway but reading the
comic is fun I also need to meditate and
just literally breathe from my diaphragm
so get the sleep do you need
that's super critical you do not need to
set an alarm sleep as much as you need
to and by the way if you're doing things
that are exciting to you you're I know
people some of you are gonna believe me
because I hopefully I've earned the
credibility with you up to this point
and some of you're gonna call total
bullsh you can ask my wife I can set an
internal alarm clock in my mind only if
I'm excited about something or really
stressed out but that's a whole nother
thing which I try hardly to do ever but
when I'm really excited about something
I can set an internal alarm clock this
morning I told myself wake up at 4:15
what time did I wake up boys and girls
not for 14 not for 16 I woke up at 4:15
because that was the time that I told
myself to wake up I can usually get
within 5 minutes of what time I tell
myself to wake up it doesn't always work
and if I'm tired I don't give myself
that edict I tell myself to sleep as
much as I need but when I'm really
excited about something there's
something I want to get up and work on
and I'm afraid there just won't be
enough time and it's a reasonable amount
of sleep I'll say anything north of 5
hours I can usually get myself to just
wake up so get the sleep prioritize
cognitive optimization because then
you're efficient and efficiency is the
name of the game so sleep sleep sleep
I'm not a guy proposing the you know set
your alarm get up at 4:00 a.m. no matter
what it's not me go to bed early get
your sleep meditate getting a good
peaceful calm creative state so that you
can really crush it rule number five
explore life would you be in favor of
college students or anyone that may be
considering it to take some time off to
travel and experience as many new things
as they can in order to find themselves
so absolutely but not to find themselves
so you create yourself you decide who
you want to become
but figure
hang out who it is that you want to
become that is something that requires
you to encounter a lot of things to
experience a lot of life this is Kevin
Kelly's whole notion of don't
prematurely optimize I think that some
of the best advice young people are ever
going to hear is you really want to go
out and explore discover new things so
that you can find what it is that you
find interesting
then that's where the discovery process
ends in the developing process begins
then you begin to create this notion of
who you want to become and then you go
down the path of becoming that gaining
those skills developing mastery in a
certain area but first really make sure
because you're gonna give at least a
decade of your life if not more to any
one thing so making sure that that's
something that fills you up instead of
chipping away at you is really really
important and the only way to do that is
to experience a whole lot of stuff so
yeah I have no beef with taking that
time off to go explore and discover new
things I think it's incredibly powerful
rule number six be yourself you've got
two choices in life choice one you can
become somebody else choice - you can
become yourself now I really wish that
there was only one choice but in truth
there's not and most people choose to
try to become someone else because it's
a road map
it's points in a direction you see
someone you respond to something you
admire them you want to be like them and
in that process you've made your
decision in that process you decided to
become somebody else you have mistaken
the finger for the moon instead you need
to understand them being inspired by
somebody does not mean to become that
person to become that which inspires you
it is to understand fundamentally what
is it about that thing that excites you
what is it what is its essence
and when you can find its essence then
you can find out how it would apply to
you becoming you and as Zen she says
flower does not think about competing
with the flower next to it it just
blooms and that's really your job is to
see the outside world to see the flower
next to you to understand the amazing
things that are happening all around you
all of the incredible people and the
essence of what they have and what it is
that they've done to bring inside
yourself and find out what does that
look like when it's me not what do I
look like when I'm them and once you
understand the difference between that
then you can really begin to be
something unique you can become that
thing that you were meant to be that
thing that makes you feel alive and
whole and that's it that's the secret
you're just trying to be something not
that's just inspiring to other people
that you actually want to wake up every
day and be thing about it so escaping
you whatever you become a lie the truth
somebody else yourself whatever it is
mr. anyway
of your life there
and his Albert Einstein said everybody
is a genius but if you judge a fish by
its ability to climb a tree it will live
it's whole life believing that it's
stupid
that's what confuses people people
believe that they're done because
they're not finding their path they're
not defining things based on what
excites them and what they want to live
with
they're just looking to what the outside
world says is good and I think it's
incredible that there are other people
doing things that are so extraordinary
that we aspire to be like that you have
to understand the difference between
being like someone and trying to
actually be
rule number seven have self-esteem we
talk of self-esteem in one of two ways
either as the sole determinant of
success or as the ultimate enemy most
people build their self-esteem around
their accomplishments they feel good
about themselves if they're making the
most money they're dating the hottest
person or they've built the best product
they get caught in the rat race of
validating themselves against the person
who happens to be standing next to them
but there's a fundamental flaw with this
equation because when your ego is that
attached to your success its devastated
by your failures and what the most
successful people know is you cannot
leave your self-worth in the hands of
anyone else the most successful people
get their pride from the different
source one that does not fluctuate with
their successes and failures so I knew I
couldn't give up my self-esteem I
couldn't accept some weird role where I
just was always the dumbass sitting in
the corner if I pride myself on being
smart and you tell me I'm dumb and you
put up a pretty good case for it that's
gonna damage my self-esteem my
self-esteem in that situation is very
fragile
if on the other hand you tell me that
I'm dumb and I build my self-esteem
around being the learner now I'm gonna
say thank you please tell me in what way
that I'm dumb because you will open my
eyes to something that now I can address
and I can go learn about that thing and
I will have a new skill and I can go out
and push and execute against that skill
one of the most powerful things that you
could do is become the person that
admits that you're wrong really fast and
it's crazy how much credibility you'll
learn with people simply by admitting I
was wrong like 30 seconds ago I was
fighting so hard for something I was
really fighting for my position and then
somebody says something and I realized
that's actually better imagine that the
more you try to tell me I'm dumb the
more areas that you point out that I'm
weak the more things you tell me I need
to learn about my eyes are open to
something that it's true I'm gonna go
down that path and I'm gonna learn how
to
and that is absolutely critical rule
number eight build your reality what are
your thoughts on changing reality with
thoughts and repetitions will this
workers adjust a theory okay so there's
no doubt that the way that the brain
rewires itself is through repetition
neurons that fire together wire together
so you very much can create reality I
want to say that it isn't unfortunately
like the matrix but it's so close that
you might as well think of it like that
but to me that's just a metaphor to get
people to understand that you really can
influence your your hardwiring in your
own brain and you certainly can
influence the outside world by gaining a
set of skills that allow you to go out
and manipulate it I'll give you a super
easy example learning to build a house
means you can actually build a house and
you can manifest that and turn a tree or
concrete into a physical structure so
you can definitely have that kind of
influence you can obviously influence
other people by learning about
psychology so all of these things are
very very possible rule number nine my
personal favorite change your beliefs
the matrix has you now the matrix to me
is a simple metaphor I don't actually
believe that we're living in the
computer simulation and even if we are I
don't think that it matters but what
does matter is your entire life is being
lived by your brain now what do I mean
by that if you know a guy named David
Eagleman he wrote a book called
incognito in the book incognito he makes
one thing abundantly clear you live in a
virtual environment whether you realize
it or not that virtual environment is
created by the three pounds of squishy
material between your ears
think about this your brain never
touches light your brain is encased in a
bone box in total darkness and yet it
takes photons that fall on the eye and
turns it into electrochemical stimulus
and from that it paints this environment
it fakes the sense of depth think about
this for a second there's not some
little image of this room projected into
the back of my mind this is all being
turned into electrochemical stimulus and
my brain then manufactures this
environment
there's actually
dime spot blank part in your field of
vision where each optic nerve connects
to your eyes and yet you have no
experience of it that it's completely
invisible to you even though it's
massive and it's dead center in your
eyes the reason that you don't
experience it is because your brain
fills it in your brain makes a guess as
to what would be there and your brain is
so good at guessing and so good at
presenting it as if it were real that
you have no sense it is completely
seamless to you when I heard that I
remember getting the chills and setting
the book down and saying my brain is
lying to me
that rat now the question becomes if
this is all made up if the sense of
distance between you and I is completely
manufactured by my brain and it's not
real meaning what I see of it it's real
enough and that if I walk I'll hit you
at about the point that I'm expecting to
bump into you because my brain can
create that sense of distance but it's
doing it by translating those signals
it's manufacturing this space so if
that's true and my brain fills in the
gaps does my brain also have biases and
the answer is yes neuroscience has gone
deep into how many different biases that
we have as humans I'll give you one
because this one is profoundly impactful
you're more likely to believe something
negative than you are something positive
now think about how that can echo
through your life each of us has to
realize that all of the beliefs that we
have in our life are choices the scary
part about the most important beliefs in
your life as most of them are invisible
I'm going to give you a couple questions
that will highlight invisible beliefs
that you have that are controlling your
life that are exactly why I say the
matrix has you because depending on how
you answer these questions will
determine your life and if you don't
recognize something scary in your own
answers think about the people that you
love that you want to help and you can't
and you wonder why the answer is almost
certainly related to how they answer
some of these questions number one this
comes from Einstein he said the most
important decision
the most important decision any human
being must make is whether or not you
live in a friendly or a hostile universe
now we could have said realization but
he didn't he said decision you have to
decide because there is no empirical
truth you don't live in either a
friendly or a hostile universe you
decide and that perception that
viewpoint from which you judge
everything else that happens in your
life will be colored by whether or not
you think it is a universe that is
working for you or against you and it's
a choice but most people think of their
viewpoint is being patently real as
being just objective and true and so
they never stop to question the fact
that they actually decided that at some
point either because their parents acted
in accordance with that it was either
hostile or friendly and they just
absorbed that or their friends or the
people that they work with or whatever
but somewhere along the line they came
to believe that they live in either a
friendly or a hostile universe but you
could change right now right now you
could make a different decision and if
you believe that the world is working
against you right now you could choose
to believe that it's actually working
for you and in making a fundamentally
new and different assumption it empowers
you to move forward and this is
something that I will repeat in this
talk the reason that matters is human
beings do not invest energy in things
that they don't think will yield a
result and rule number 10 the last one
before a very special bonus clip is
enjoy the moment as Martin Luther said
even if I knew that tomorrow the world
would go to pieces I would still plant
my apple tree some things you build
whether you can control the outcome or
not sometimes it's the process that is
the thing that's meant to be enjoyed
it's the process that you're meant to
invest in and rather than always
thinking about the goal the outcome or
what you're going to get out of
something focus on to something focus on
the part of it that you can control
because you can't always control the
outcome you can't know what's going to
happen to
tomorrow's not guaranteed to any of us
and yet we all act and yet we create
momentum in our lives and we're at our
best but we do that not because we can
control every aspect we do that because
we accept that there are things that we
cannot control
and as steve maraboli said incredible
change happens in your life when you
decide to take control of what you do
have power over instead of craving
control over what you don't and that's
where a lot of people get lost
they focus not on what they have in
their hands they focus instead on the
things that they can't control it
irritates them it frustrates them it's
like a splinter in their mind they can't
stop thinking about the things that they
don't have control over and they're
blinded to the incredible wealth that is
around them of things that they could
enjoy right here right now
that's why gratitude is such an
empowering practice to sit there and not
think of the glorious things may await
you in your future but rather to think
about the things that you have here in
this moment oxygen in your lungs a
simple breeze on your face a window in
your house someone that you love someone
that loves you nothing that costs money
nothing that was the pot of gold at the
end of a glorious rainbow it's not even
about becoming something extraordinary
and waiting for the results of that it's
simply understanding that the one thing
you can control are your actions today
the choices that you make what you
get to do how you think about yourself
the beliefs you choose to bring into
your life those things you control and
when you understand the power in
acknowledging that control and taking
control and using it that's when your
life is going to begin to change but
first you have to divorce yourself from
being obsessively interested only in an
outcome if instead you build your
self-esteem you build your pride on
pursuit you build your pride and
allowing yourself to care about
something so deeply that even though
tomorrow is not guaranteed that you're
going to plant your apple tree today
that you're going to love that process
because it is the thing that you can
control you can control how you show up
you can control how you play you cannot
control how other people react you
cannot control what they think about you
but you can control what you think about
yourself you can earn credibility with
yourself you can control what you do and
when you take full ownership of that and
realize that your life is an exact
reflection of the GWAR choices of the
things you could control and what you
did with them then everything begins to
change you're not looking to blame
somebody else you're not even worried
anybody else you're just asking one
simple question what can I do right now
regardless of tomorrow to improve my
life today
focus there and you'll enjoy every day
of your life
now I've got a really special bonus Tom
Beale you clip on how to develop your
passion that I think you're really gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions I want you
to move from watch another video to
actually taking action in your life and
in your business so answer these
questions by yourself talk about them
with a friend or leave your answers down
in the comments below here we go
question number one what beliefs about
yourself do you need to change to reach
your goals question number two how can
you optimize your life to make these
beliefs stick and question number three
what will you do on a daily basis to
boost your self-esteem thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon and enjoy the bonus
clip
how do I find my passion asking how you
find your passion makes the assumption
that your passion has been lost
somewhere your passion has not been lost
your passion has never been developed
her passions are created they're
constructed they're developed and it
starts with interest one of the greatest
misconceptions of our time is that your
passion is something hidden inside of
you Michael Jordan wasn't born dreaming
of slam dunks Bill Gates first word was
in Microsoft even Elon Musk didn't start
by reaching for Mars but there is
something different about these
extraordinary minds but it isn't what
they were born with
it's something they had to learn to
build brick by brick now that you've got
to start going deep into gaining mastery
and it's in the process of gaining
mastery that you're gonna find out if
that interest turns into a love then
turns into a passion people who are
passionate are willing to fight through
the boredom
now they're not doing it thinking oh my
god this is so much fun
they're thinking I want to win I want to
play at the highest level and I am
willing to break myself in half and this
is the thing that I cannot get
entrepreneurs to understand if you want
to be great I promise you as Tommy said
you already have any what you need which
is the ultimate evolution approved
ability to adapt so you can change to
get great you can change to become
whatever you need
to literally break themselves and have
to get the result that they want your
passion isn't something hidden inside of
you it's going to reveal itself
magically over a cup of coffee it is not
going to come knocking at your door it's
something you have to go out and build
altruistic world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think I see
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what gary vee DJ khalid
oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video